les coûts augmenteront pour les riches et pour les
grandes entreprises et pour
les familles de la classe moyenne qui travaillent dur, les coûts diminueront
à la fin de la journée, l'écrasante
majorité des gens économisera de l'argent sur
leurs factures de soins de santé, mais je pense
qu'il convient de reconnaître  que les
impôts vont augmenter, ils vont augmenter de
manière significative pour que les riches débarquent
spook et Danny distillent le démocrate s'opposent à
la dure manipulation du taxi Amiri est venu
Ciro Bustos tante Ella LaHood tyrannie
Busha sentiment professeur dick sait
bibliquement pas bonsoir
Templeton de peraleda soirée pyjama
una  tradición sua création graphique a
politique mr.  Simon zucman
no donghae zucman confesseur
réparation de roman graphique Italica wove bien attaque la
partie ACO lorsque les déposants font
le jeune Watley Aramaki de Moyes Oprah Bernie
Sanders tirer vers le haut l'oscillation c'était
kazuto-san taxation extrême imposer un
voir important présenter une clémence commune d'
elizabeth komova venir acides
Le dollar de Farrakhan pour  arbitraire biélorussie
SEK fouette la voix hola chef chef du parti
considère Sanders comme une voix de Warren
mal personnellement préférable à la
chimio fiscale une semaine mr.  Biden mon costume Ron
al-ahqaf Lula personne Seligman Bella s'arrange
toujours pour éviter d'augmenter la
prison prison VD à la fiscalité elle
apparaîtra comme non-conformiste vous leur achetez un
costume sur
ne pas vraiment purée elle voit une partie
du chat restant 10% nous exact  Emma
ne fuit pas la serrure polonaise Pisani
émancipe Pamela depuis que Biden c'est faux exact
mmm correct Rumpy Biden un zap riant
mon nom piscine
il permet de joindre notre meilleur
menu de dépositions d'aujourd'hui devant vous puisque juste
et substantiel aura est publié à
la chimie Sanders au-delà d'un  fresca
Santos une antilope acridienne que vous souhaiteriez à madame
Warren reste
Dallas était sur le jumeau du Congrès un
dr.  Warren a Sanders a proposé l'
ancien mamelon important Polly, s'il vous plaît,
examinons-en quelques-uns. Larry dit que le revenu de la personne au
Brésil qu'ils suçaient sur le
cas du professeur de revenu ne fait que surgir avec
un principe que la ville descend do
Mizzou pour la prime de Mottola Adam
Warren a proposé le taxi do post  et
Larry, elle est un petit épisode actif,
la synchronisation d'un million comme le chat
Amelia perrito pasa Liz active Don
contraint à s'approprier un en l'honneur de prenons-le
sur le citron fiscal un exemple d'examen
paneer masala masseuse endure propose
ce qui suit me montre l'homme qui
le personnel de l'héritage de la police a tué le pouvoir à quel
moment merci de notre personnel est actif,
engagez simplement des personnalités actives Pugh
vient de perdre quand ils ont passé ce média
le total des revenus de l'eau pour améliorer les
services perdure nous proposons uniquement le
retour de l'impôt n'a pas besoin de Lagavulin fan d'
attaques se produisent  et l'échantillon sert bien comme
c'était sur cette partie si longtemps quand
il transférait le parens alpha
et conduisait également le spel ordinaire  l pour la chatte
au comité mademoiselle Leveaux Sidhu vient
papa marque ça ne quad moins la poêle est
un livre de présent potentiellement joueur
voit que la prison du rein de Bernie Sanders
c'était une dope la sociétale un
Kangol un tueur un peu justifier la
prison épique de danse télévisée  publier visuellement un
aspirateur ascendeurs re dire le point principaux
composés dirigés de en webetest
registre moustique multi-voies caca
fiscalité chatouilleuse ici duc prendre sa retraite pauvre
analogie vie squelette si longtemps tué
duc Tyrell réfléchir à la vue sur l'
étang que nous connaissons comme une chanson supposons qu'ils ont
autorisé les tamis le  moniker la
description que Larry partage, donc ce sont des devatas, ce qui est
important, personnellement, je ressens une
plongée sur Terra sur la question de la
proposition de mission de terrorisme, monsieur,
occupe la logistique sur un système mixte de
points que j'ai tué S Kalikow a
reproduit un garage karai basmala
plus rapidement dans mon Mac raisonnablement  son
marché Keeley papazoni sur cycle song
limited Cecil est plutôt en sécurité à Hawaï à
distance ici à côté du tweet le jock
rencontrer un seul village NPD Pascoe cetera
Lolita Gelman un PDG italique Canada a
illa llah Tweety élection Alexandra
Yokosuka Teske représente un tout original
à New York Polly démocratie taxe les riches
en taxi à pied vraiment un imbécile réunions des
éternités verront la popularité si grande échelle
poinsettias un autre  l'État arrête
le point de Pascal, nous pouvons ajouter un sur un v12 un
peu de recul des
échelles d'opposition politique Levin [ __ ] a proposé que le
filament d'accélération manyara madame
veux devenir pour San Soo Liz actif
un peu également concerné le nouvel
exemple d'un nouvel exemple EP Calchas le
calcul des enfants Napoli Pradesh
la proposition des musulmans non carbonés sonne si nous
ne faisons que l'opposition conservatrice malléable un
caca comme le dernier kilomètre de ce qui reste
wha arbitrage de l'éternité
description du photographe P si seulement des livres électroniques et Larry
dit que le capot est actif faux positif
j'ai tué poley Rochon capable le
de plus  permet d'accéder à votre
loi importante Mesa plus une procédure d'
incendie en argent dollar plus d'attaques diminuent g  comme les
attaques de Malala étaient innovantes du nouveau
réceptacle ViCAP Abdul Muttalib,
le père une description qui Canada
Pascal ce serait fantaisiste est vaguement
citoyen EOPS mesnick est un professeur de livre
le jour plus c'est l'
écologie du capot activiste colon américain civil ce n'est pas
une maladie ni la pauvreté  un public en
mobilité monte convertir le Plessy
passons juste convertir axillaire
purush immobilité c'est juste moi allez craquer
inutile Cal sondé des chansons très populaires
nous laisseraient à l'échelle ooh
Pascal ils ont dit aujourd'hui mon propre condo
sédiments est actif des dizaines de
taxes supplémentaires  sur le film d'attaques d'avertissement alibis
pas une réduction évoluons vin stupide
que tout voir loin kazoo kazoo
pour un démon est un effet principal citron sur
un parti pris la taxation des aérosols âne
Andrew important Lizabeth Warren Bernie
Sanders supervise la campagne démocrate
merci beaucoup Les diadèmes représentent la
miséricorde d'Emma